[Musique]
ce mardi 30 août le président du
département cyrille melchior s'est rendu
à terrain fleury sur la commune du
tampon pour accueillir les résidents du
nouvel ehpad de la fondation père favron
il revient au département
d'élargir l'offre de places pour les
personnes âgées mais aussi pour les
personnes porteuses de handicap on le
fait bien sûr en lien avec l'agencé
régionale de santé les municipalités et
des associations qui sont indiens les
opérateurs qui réalise concrètement les
projets le département apporte des
financements nous signons donc chaque
année donc au fil des années donc d
autorisation d'ouvrir donc des
établissements d'accueil est aussi ici
au tampon après divers aléas il a fallu
du temps mais enfin cet ehpad de 83
places est meilleur aujourd'hui
accueilli les premiers résidents il dit
à l'ats une volonté je dirais politique
mais une volonté humaniste parce que
nous voulons le meilleur accueil à nos
personnes prennent aux aînés basée sur
la philosophie de l'humanitude cet
établissement a pour ambition de changer
le regard sur l'ehpad les 83 résidents
auront accès à un musée une ferme
pédagogique un bistrot un spa une
épicerie ou encore un salon de coiffure
donc il s'agit d'un projet
d'établissement assez important qui
nécessite une réorganisation profonde
est là pour la formation de l'ensemble
des professionnels on essaye de
travailler aussi sur plusieurs aspects
tout ce qui est culture patrimoine
histoire art
notamment par
l'intégration à ce projet de galerie
d'exposition de convention avec le
département sur la côte est l'icône
hotech également on essaye de travailler
sur la verticalité ci ont diminué au
maximum des fauteuils roulants
travailler sur la verticalisation vivre
et vieillir debout donc il est aussi
l'un des principes et les lads de la
philosophie humanitude et puis des
professionnels qui travaillent en civil
au quotidien pour essayer de limiter
justement à l'interaction soignant
soigné et l'image parfois trop médical
qu'on a au sein des établissements visés
pas notamment il faut que les risques
d'un reste de mots on veut pas des gens
qu'ils soient assis au fauteuil
permanence ou à loger dans leur lit au
contraire il faut qu'il y ait de
l'animation il faut que les personnes se
sentent bien ici à mon avis
c'est tout ce que tu répond parfaitement
à cet objectif
pour les résidents et leurs proches les
pattes de terrain fleury est une
réussite le personnel est super très
gentils accueillants ses regards on peut
lui en parler c'est super les patients
est bien gentil et les gens qui
travaillent aussi est gentil avec nous
la visite s'est clôturée par une
distribution aux résidents de paniers
gourmands un dispositif du plan
bien-être conduit par le département
[Musique]